[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to GameSpot
c3 stage I'm Mike McCarty here with Lucy
James hey and we are here with Sony Ben
I'm here with John Garvin and Jeff Ross
from salumi Oh making days gone how you
guys doing good got this trail going so
far awesome had a really good show so
far yeah so far yeah so I mean like I
think last month maybe you were showing
off a ton of gameplay with the game I
know like Game Informer was showing off
a lot of the coverage and I got to watch
a lot of that what's it like showing it
off at e3 it's really cool because it's
actually live and playable therefore
it's you know in the press room but
we've got two pieces of content that
we're playing one of them features the
hoard that we showed you know two years
ago and it's fully playable it's it's
running at a great framerate the world
looks gorgeous and people are dying and
some people are surviving and they're
enjoying every bit of it so it's pretty
cool so what is that what is that demo
you're showing on this done floor like I
like what can people do in the demo that
you still have so we have a couple of
demos we have the Horde demo and we also
have the crazy willies demo so it's
basically this mission where Deacon and
Boozer have to get a mic part for Deacon
and they stop by this infested truck
stop and if you saw it last month
because we because the game former guys
played it there you know you watch this
version of it again like Jeff said the
performance is 100% improved we're
targeting 30 frames a second we've hit
that for the ps4 Pro and the ps4 so for
that and the Horde demo so pretty
excited to have people play it because
it makes a huge difference yeah for sure
yeah I'm curious as a zombie game right
like it's it's funny I feel like there
was a few years where there weren't as
many zombie games but then all of a
sudden they come back there's dying like
- is the show you guys are at the show
state of decay to just release any of
they are billions the RTS like I don't
know is there's like something you can
attribute that like why do you think
that these zombie games are making such
a comeback I mean if they even ever went
anywhere well yeah you know our game is
not just about freaker's you know we do
have a dynamically populated world with
their response to the way the players
play and it's a bunch of survivors a
bunch of you
and creatures animals that have survived
and changed they're all alive they all
actively hunt meat that's you know
they're not looking for brains and it's
it's freaker's it's human beings are
kind of like what probably one of our
nastier enemies we've got our massive
hoards that roam the landscape we've got
animals we've got infected animals all
these people are somewhere in the food
chain and they're kind of fighting to
survive and so we don't consider
ourselves just a game like that anymore
well other fingers themselves I think
are kind of unique to us because they're
living beings yeah they're not the
undead and they they need to have a
day/night cycle they need a hibernate
they need to eat they need to drink and
you can learn their patterns so you
learn which types of freaker's where
they live why they live there and like
Jeff said they just the the virus the
the pandemic that killed the world
infects more than just human beings and
you can see all sorts of infected
animals in the world they all present
unique challenges and for us it was like
we you know we want to build an open
world game that was dangerous and to
have it be constantly dangerous it has
to be more than just Marauders and
rippers and animals you need like a
constant threat and so that's one of the
things I think that makes days not
unique is that the world itself is
always out to get you and no matter what
you're trying to do you're in danger of
dying send-up percent a kind of moral
quandary as you're playing because if
the Freak is are still alive like I
guess you when you consider zombies
you're like on the dead like it's not
really any skin off my nose to kill them
but a frico that kind of may be still in
there no they're not at all feral
they're cannibalistic and you learn
actually during the course the game you
learn what happened and you kind of
learn how they got to be that way what
the virus is doing to them so that's one
of the things the player is gonna
discover as they play
okay so we're playing as Deacon st. John
yes what what like how does he find
himself in this situation what's his
backstory and how is he gonna cope with
the the hoards that's coming after him
again that's one of the things that
we're hoping the player discovers so we
haven't talked a lot about the story but
you know I can tell you this much it's
from the trailers we've already revealed
you can see the Deacon is a broken man
he was a member of an outlaw MC
his only friend his brother basically
boozers is survived with him and the two
of had to rely on each other from the
beginning of the apocalypse so you learn
what happened before you learn you know
how he got to be this way how he got to
be so broken he lost someone and you
know you know like Jeff says everybody
loses somebody in an apocalypse and
everybody deals with it differently and
so one of the things we really wanted to
explore was how would you deal with it
you know so that's why we wanted to keep
the world as realistic as possible if
relatable as possible and the character
I think is relatable as possible one
thing I want to add about it is there's
a reason that deacon is our hero you
know it's not just a random choice
this guy was perfectly suited to survive
the apocalypse and this is why we're
telling his story because you know we've
got these we've got a broken road where
it's destroyed it's eroding at this
point but there's traffic jams galore
and you know that's where everybody died
and Deacon is a guy who never went to
the authorities he never needed their
help and he had his motorcycle so when
when the roads are choked off and hordes
were eating people stuck in traffic jams
he was able to split lanes and get the
hell out and go off road and that's kind
of what makes him the perfect survivor
and the perfect protagonist for this
campus he's good with a baseball bat
yeah right and like I said the whole
thing about Brotherhood so you know you
think of it outlaw bikers you think okay
these guys are really violent they're
criminals but they also have this you
know this love of the open road and this
sense of brotherhood with each other a
sense of loyalty that that's pretty hard
to match anywhere else but obviously the
bike plays a huge part not only in terms
of the story but in terms of the
gameplay can you talk a little bit more
about like having to refuel a biking and
maintaining it and what that brings to
the gameplay so we really wanted to
capture you know I think when we talk
about wire you know where apocalyptic
games so popular I think it's because
people they feel like they've got what
what it takes to survive I mean who
really wants to but we feel if we're
pressed we could do it and we said we
wanted to capture a survival element of
this type of genre and but we wanted the
game to be kind of up pace and upbeat
and kind of not not be bogged down at a
bunch of you know searching for food and
water for the player but it really kind
of made a lot of sense to just move
those elements to the bike and just by
having to maintain fuel you know I can't
think of any game that's really
you know there might have been a couple
but I can't even think those it's just
it's it's counterintuitive but it feels
right it's like when you're buying this
game you want to the players want the
fantasy of being in the apocalypse and
the bike is what reminds them that
they're real that the world is relatable
and it leads to some great moments
because the bike is deikun's advantage
like I talked about earlier and anytime
he's yeah he has to go without it
the world becomes extremely even more
dangerous than it was before because now
he's he's back to where all the other
survivors were and he's got the scrounge
and scavenged to find that gas that
leads to really great emergent moments
of fear and danger and risk and you know
the bike is is my collection another
care it's like another character but the
functionality in this mission right here
on the back of his bike he's got a fully
upgraded set of saddlebags where he can
carry extra ammo into the field whereas
before he'd really have to scavenge for
a few bullets here there and when he's
taking on a horde of 250 or more kind of
helps to have a lot of extra ammo so
when you need a top-off go back to your
bike if you can't find it in the
environment so it is a personality in
the story but as far as the gameplay
progression systems go it's also a huge
personality can you talk about some of
the some of the things you've done with
this open world to make it feel
constantly dangerous threatening yeah
ambushes I think is my favorite is the
yeah so in the trailer we just dropped
they have you see beacon is riding down
the road and he gets hit by sniper fire
yeah and we've shown like clothes lining
in you know there's all sorts of booby
traps that the Marauders will lay out
for you so one of the things we really
want to do is like make the roads
dangerous so you can take on the ambush
camps and if you clear them out at a
given area it will make the roads
actually safer so it's one of the ways
we get the player to engage in the open
world and try to make it a safer place
and then there's animals animals that
can run faster than you so the thicker
wolves they can they can knock the often
same thing with the crows which we just
introduced which we call Criers they can
bombard you and you know you want to try
to avoid them when you're riding through
the world so I mean taste gun is the
first big major release you guys have
had since you did golden Abyss on the
Vita
what's it like you know going moving
from a game from the Vita on a lot of
franchise the
was you know created by another studio
and coming out with something of your
own it's amazing yeah it's been since
Syphon Filter one was our last new IP
and that's been a few years ago so yeah
you know and it's like it it's just
amazing be able to work on this platform
with you know having these kinds of
production values and you know a team of
creative people so we went from working
like I think it was like 50 people that
did that did golden Abyss and we're now
at like 130 and you know everybody just
really really contributes at a super
high level because that's still pretty
small yeah compared to other studios and
I think you know it makes it makes it a
lot of fun to work on the game and so
it's it's a in addition to the new IP
just creating the new gameplay paradigm
forward has been you know it's been a
challenge and it's been thrilling and
just you know that's been a journey unto
itself but yeah it's been a long time
since going abyss right yeah you know
it's it is cool to have something almost
ready to come out yeah so we're thrilled
about that part of it as well how do you
go about creating like a feedback loop
in terms of the gameplay where you know
you want to get out and explore you want
to have a fight but then you kind of
want to dial down the intensity a bit
how do you go about kind of perfecting
that and implementing it in an
open-world you know pacing is huge in a
game like this where there's a fine line
between getting ambushed too many times
and not enough to if it's if not enough
obviously the world doesn't feel
threatening if you do it too much and
all of a sudden the loses its impact so
we've kind of developed systems to kind
of help it deliberately intentional
pacing systems so you know we built
those the tuning for it's ongoing to get
it right a game like this is so massive
that you just have to play it for really
long loops to kind of appreciate it if
you you know to appreciate that pacing
and and that's the key dude it's like we
have play tests all the time so we have
bring 20 players in as a group and they
play the entire game and we have we
report all their metrics we videotape
them playing and then we just that's the
only way you can really know is just how
you can't even ask some questions you
really have to watch them play and see
okay they're frustrated or they're
having fun here or they really enjoyed
that and that's the only way you can
really tune an experience like this is
by playing it
and I know like when developers are
focused on their own games it's very
difficult to like you know it keep your
eyes on all the games coming out around
you and I know it's it can tend to be
very you know like laser focus but what
kind of are there any games that you
guys have specifically been heavily
inspired by in recent years that have
been contributing to days gone
definitely God war ism is an amazing
game I think Santa Monica studio did an
amazing job with that so that was that
was a lot of fun it was a lot it was
awesome to see the success that it's had
as well so super impressed by that and
then what about like other types of
media I mean like again like it you said
like freaker's you're setting yourself
apart with you like with the freaker's
and the story that you're gonna be
telling but either in each specific
movies anything that actually like
really play into this huge fan of The
Walking Dead so I read the comics watch
the TV series I used to watch fear The
Walking Dead I haven't really kind of
kept up with ok you and me both sam
witwer in playing Deacon st. John what
was the like casting process behind
getting him involved I'm sorry what was
the casting process like to get Sam
Witwer involved Oh
so the yeah so he was we cast him very
early on because we wanted to do a
digital double right so the three main
characters in the game you've seen two
of them they were all digital doubles
and you know and so he has he has like
that chiseled look that we were looking
for you know he's believable in the part
well I think actually most importantly
you know we're not we weren't saying
what were fed I don't even know who he
was but I remember looking at his
audition tape and saying hey this is the
first one who we saw who actually can
act and it listens and responds and you
know yeah he turned out to be handsome
and chiseled like John points out and
and pretty accomplished and in a fan
favorite but we cast him pretty
organically just based on the merits
well I knew he was but but the but I
hadn't you know but I'm I wasn't a fan
yeah the way he's got a lot of fans but
he's really super talented and if you
didn't know he's also a huge gamer so
that really helped that he's like
involved in the process and it's super
curious about it and let me tell you the
amount of the number of
hours we spent on the mocap stage and
the vo booth you have to be dedicated to
do that because it's really hard on your
vocal cords and yeah the guy's a trooper
I want to get your take I'm always
curious it seems like survival is a
growing trend in games I mean even more
so than the last few years I mean
fallout 76 it's focusing on it and it
seems like it's the it's almost may be
the next big thing to be a little bit
reductive but I'm curious from your
point of view making days gone in a game
that it has a very perilous world
there's like almost the whole time
sounds like what you're aiming for what
is it about survival games that might
our game sorry not saint games based
around survival and dangerous worlds
that makes them so appealing
oh well it's like Jeff said earlier that
it's a fantasy it's like I think
everybody has that fantasy it's like
that if the asteroid hits tomorrow and
the world is decimated what am I gonna
do you know and I think everybody you
know so it's a very very popular fantasy
and I think being able to explore that
interactively is amazing so and you know
it's like you you can you can test
yourself yeah and I call it action
survival you know again we're we we kind
of want to do it as gamers but we don't
wanna get bogged down with all that
minutia so I think that there's
definitely hardcore survival we are
trying to kind of forge this action
survival tear of the survival genre in
general where it's just it's a taste of
it it's on the bike it's keep it it
keeps you grounded and relatable and I
think it does kind of come back to that
is we want game so we can relate to a
lot more that mean the better they look
you know the greater the graphics are
becoming it is kind of beckoning
mechanics that feel a little bit more
realistic than you know conventional
things we've been getting getting away
with frankly for the last 20-30 years
like in our case the we call it the
broken road so all the highways the
bridge has been destroyed the highways
you know gone without me
it's for a couple of years and if you've
ever been to Central Oregon you know
that's like wow that's really horrible
because the it gets super cold then it
gets super hot and then everything just
cracks up and it's it's amazing way more
fun to ride your bike on that that it is
just running down riding down the
straight highway so you have jumps in
the world that have been created by you
know by pieces of asphalt that have sort
of shifted up and it's all organic and
it's just fun to be in and it looks
really really interesting it's like the
thing about a post-apocalyptic worlds is
slight amount of decay or twenty
thousand years or the decayed doesn't
matter it just creates an interesting
landscape so visually it's it's it's fun
and in the terms of gameplay it's fun
and it's set in the Pacific Northwest as
well which I believe is your guy's like
backyard what was it like kind of
creating that world for your game so for
us it's about the high desert so yeah
it's in Central Oregon but the entire
Pacific Northwest if you're east of the
Cascade Range is high desert and that
basically means extreme so it's extreme
weather in fact the day before we left
it's like it was like oh it's starting
to snow and it's starting to rain and
now it's sunny and that could all happen
in the same day and then it's the biomes
are very very compressed so you know we
live right outside of the Badlands which
is like a stretch of desert and then if
you go to the west just 20 miles you're
in you're at an alpine forest and they
have everything scarred by volcanic
activity from millions of years ago so
we have all these great Montana peaks
and caves and tunnels and it's just you
know it's like that's the high desert
and you I haven't seen any games that
have been set there alright so for those
watching who might not have might have
missed out on it when can people play
days gone February 22nd and thank you so
much John and Jeff for coming up on our
stage proportionally that is all the
time we have but I hope you have a great
rest of a 3-week thank you so much with
everything from here on out if you're
watching from home don't go anywhere we
will be right back with total war three
kingdoms we'll see you then